ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen es
ist Tag 112 im ukrainekrieg und die Lage
im Osten des Landes scheint sich für die
Ukraine nicht zu verbessern im Gegenteil
die Verteidiger könnten den Kampf um die
Don bassregion schon bald verloren haben
Präsident selenski drängt immer wieder
darauf dass westliche Staaten auch
Deutschland schneller und mehr Waffen
liefern und militärische Ausrüstung
natürlich um der russischen Übermacht
standhalten zu können hat Russland also
nach anfänglichen Schwierigkeiten nun
die Oberhand gewonnen unterstützt der
Westen genug welche Waffen wurden schon
geliefert und sollte Deutschland davon
noch mehr exportieren diese Fragen
wollen wir heute mit euch diskutieren
und wir sprechen dazu später in der
Sendung mit dem Militärexperten Gustav
gressel aber zunächst schalten wir zu
unseren Kollegen Julia Held nach Kiew
und zu Florian neuer nach Brüssel wo
sich heute die NATO
Verteidigungsminister zu Beratungen
treffen fangen wir mal in der Ukraine an
Julia das wünscht sich die Ukraine von
der NATO welche Hoffnungen verbindet man
in Kiew zunächst mal auf politischer
Ebene mit den Beratungen in Brüssel
ja die Erwartungen sind ja im Prinzip
bekannt es geht eigentlich immer wieder
um das gleiche die Forderung nach mehr
dieser sogenannten schweren Waffen das
ist ja längst so eine Art Mantra in
diesem Krieg geworden und davon lässt
die Ukraine auch nicht ab im Gegenteil
die Wunschliste die Liste ist jetzt noch
mal länger geworden da stehen inzwischen
Zahlen im Raum von denen keiner so
wirklich weiß wie die NATO-Länder sie
wirklich erfüllen sollen auf der anderen
Seite ist aber auch klar warum die
Ukraine da jetzt noch mal so den Druck
erhöht sie steht im Osten einfach extrem
unter Beschuss die russische Armee ist
von der von der feuerstärke um ein
Mehrfaches überlegen der
präsidentenberater hat jetzt von einer
20-fachen Überlegenheit gesprochen von
der russischen Seite das liegt wohl
unter anderem daran dass die russische
Seite mit ihrer Artillerie viel größere
Distanzen abdecken kann oder anders
gesagt sie können die ukrainischen
Truppen aus einer viel größeren
Entfernung angreifen und die Ukrainer
wiederum müssen viel näher ran an die
Front und bringen sich damit und die
Truppen damit natürlich auch in viel
größere Gefahr das ist also der Grund
warum die Ukraine diese schweren so
dringend braucht also
raketenabwehrwaffen vor allem um diesen
Angriffen einfach irgendwas
entgegensetzen zu können und angeblich
aber auch das allerdings ist eine eine
ukrainische Quelle sei bislang nur ein
Zehntel dessen angekommen was hier
benötigt wird also großer militärischer
Druck auf die Ukraine Florian neu an was
konkret sind denn die NATO-Staaten
bereits zu tun um die Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen
man nimmt sehr genau war hier was Julia
hält gerade beschrieben hat eben also
wie die militärische Lage im Donbass
etwa aussieht und deshalb will man in
der Tat die militärische Hilfe massiv
aufstocken hier hat sich heute
Nachmittag im Brüsseler Hauptquartier
der NATO die sogenannten Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe getroffen und der Führung
der USA und genau darüber zu reden und
es hat mehrere Ankündigungen gegeben von
diversen Staaten wie man jetzt die
Waffenlieferungen aufstockt unter
anderem von der deutschen
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht die vor einer guten Stunde
gesagt hat dass Deutschland jetzt drei
sogenannter mehrfach Raketenwerfer
schicken will in die Ukraine das ist
durchaus schweres Geschütz mit einer
Reichweite von immerhin 80 Kilometern
also es könnte der Ukraine wirklich sehr
gut helfen im aktuellen Konflikt
Lambrecht werden die USA weitere vier
dieser mehrfachraketenwerfer schicken
Großbritannien weitere drei das ist eine
neue Qualität der Waffenlieferungen in
diesem Konflikt bisher hat man ja vor
allem altes schweres Gerät sowjetischer
Bauart geliefert in die Ukraine jetzt
also erstmals auch modernes schweres
Gerät südwestlicher Bauart aber bis
diese Sachen dann bis dieses Gerät
ankommt in der Ukraine da dürfte noch
einige Zeit vergehen Frau Lambrecht
sprach gerade von August September als
Zielmarke man werde da dafür auch noch
ukrainischer Soldaten ausbilden eigens
in Deutschland aber es vergeht eben noch
etwas Zeit aktuell ganz konkret wird man
der Ukraine damit nicht helfen können
wir sprechen gleich weiter vielen Dank
bis sie hinwollen unseren Zuschauerinnen
und Zuschauern aber vorher noch mal kurz
zeigen was in der Ukraine derzeit und
was auch auf dem diplomatischen Parkett
passiert denn Bundeskanzler Scholz will
ja voraussichtlich morgen gemeinsam mit
Frankreichs Präsident macron und
italiens Regierungschef Draghi in die
Ukraine reisen
noch mehr als einem Monat erbitterter
Gefechte diese Luftaufnahmen
veröffentlicht die ukrainische Seite
heute es gibt in diesem Tagen kaum
Bilder aus der Stadt die russischen
Streitkräfte haben inzwischen
weitestgehend die Kontrolle die
ukrainischen Truppen haben sich in einem
Industriegebiet verschanzt ergeben
wollen sie sich trotz eines Ultimatums
bisher nicht auch 500 Zivilisten sollen
ukrainischen Behörden zufolge dort
ausharren die Eroberung der Stadt würde
der russischen Armee den Weg nach
slofensk und nach krematorsk der
Hauptstadt der Nachbarregion Don jetzt
eröffnen
durchhalten je mehr Verluste unser Feind
dort erleidet desto weniger Kraft wird
erhaben weiterzumachen der Donbass ist
entscheidend hier wird sich zeigen wer
in den kommenden Wochen die Oberhand
haben wird
der weil betont Frankreichs Präsident
macron beim Besuch eines
nato-stützpunktes in Rumänien das kein
Weg an Gesprächen mit Russland
vorbeiführe um den Krieg zu beenden
wenn wir alles getan haben um den
Widerstand zu unterstützen und wenn wie
ich hoffe die Ukraine gewonnen haben
wird dann müssen wir verhandeln der
ukrainische Präsident und seine
Regierung werden mit Russland verhandeln
müssen und wir Europäer wir werden mit
am Tisch sitzen um über
Sicherheitsgarantien zu sprechen über
die Dinge die unseren Kontinent angehen
so sieht die Realität aus
mit dieser Botschaft reist macron weiter
erwartet wird dass er morgen mit
Bundeskanzler Scholz und dem
italienischen Regierungschef Draghi in
Kiew eintrifft
und wir schalten noch mal nach Kiew zu
Julia Held es gibt also Erwartungen an
den Westen auch an Deutschland auch und
gerade seitens der Zivilbevölkerung auch
in der Ukraine welche Eindrücke hast du
von den Menschen auf der Straße gewinnen
können was ist der bisherige ja
Sachstand was denken sie über die
bisherige Hilfe was konkret erhoffen sie
sich jetzt auch vom Besuch des Kanzlers
ist natürlich eine Frage die wir in den
letzten Tagen vielen hier gestellt haben
oder oder es ist einfach aus den
Menschen rausgebrochen wenn wir
rausgeplatzt wenn wir Sie bei unseren
Drehs getroffen haben wenn sie gemerkt
haben dass wir aus Deutschland kommen
und ich würde sagen es ist so eine
Mischung aus Enttäuschung Frust
Unverständnis und insofern sind die
konkreten Erwartungen zumindest bei den
Menschen hier nicht gerade hoch und da
geht es nicht so sehr um die Frage die
wir in Deutschland ja immer noch
diskutieren ob dieser Besuch jetzt
vielleicht zu spät kommt oder nicht
sondern es geht glaube ich eher um so
ein grundsätzlichen Eindruck dass es in
Deutschland nach wie vor viel zu wenig
Verständnis gibt für die Situation hier
und vor allem für das Leid der Menschen
hier und das ist immer noch sehr
vielverständnis gibt für Putin das zu
viel Rücksicht auf ihn genommen wird und
das immer noch Gespräche mit ihm geführt
werden und das ist diese Sorge gibt dass
er sein Gesicht nicht verlieren durfte
und was wir hier auch zum Beispiel immer
wieder hören das ist immer noch diese
Sache mit den 5000 Helmen das ist
wirklich etwas was ich bei den Menschen
hier ganz tief eingebrannt hat was sie
glaube ich würde sagen als eine Art
Demütigung empfunden haben und das ist
etwas würde ich sagen was das Bild
Deutschlands hier wahrscheinlich für
eine lange Zeit prägen wird
vielen Dank Julia ich lese gerade mal an
der Stelle einen Kommentar vor das habe
ich für ihn vergessen zu sagen Fragen
und Kommentare natürlich wie immer gerne
an uns über entweder unsere
E-Mail-Adresse oder über die Social
Media Kanäle wann der Kalli fragt warum
lassen wir uns von Putin und Mitbewerb
drohen warum schauen wir den Morden dort
weiter untätig zu ich lasse das jetzt
mal unkommentiert stehen und gebe noch
mal die Frage an
florianeuern nach Brüssel wir hatten es
gerade auch noch mal gehört wie könnte
jetzt der weitere Fahrplan aussehen denn
das ist klar die Zeit für die Ukraine
drängt ja
wenn der Tat also der weitere Fahrplan
ist bei der NATO so dass man sich jetzt
dem in zwei Wochen in Madrid treffen
wird zum NATO-Gipfel der Staats- und
Regierungschefs da ist auch der
ukrainische Präsident wo Leute mir
selenski eingeladen sogar ein Präsenz
wenn er denn kommen möchte falls das
nicht geht aus verständlichen Gründen
wird er sich per Video zuschalten und
den Staats- und Regierungschefs dort
seine Botschaft übermitteln können man
will dort in Madrid noch mal ein großes
Hilfspaket für die Ukraine
bindeln sozusagen aber das wichtige die
wichtige Trennlinie für die NATO ist
dass sie sagt es ist nicht die NATO die
hier Waffen liefert die hier eingreift
sie will maximal Partei ergreifen aber
eben nicht Kriegspartei werden deshalb
diese feine Trennlinie die der NATO ganz
besonders wichtig ist nochmal also die
Waffen kommen von einzelnen NATO Staaten
werden koordiniert in dieser Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe geführt von den USA aber
eben nicht von der NATO und dann diese
berühmte Wunschliste die ist auch hier
aufmerksam gelesen worden die
Wunschliste des ukrainischen Präsidenten
an die westlichen Staaten da standen zum
Beispiel Dinge drauf wie 300 mehrfach
Raketenwerfer das ist wirklich utopisch
wenn man das vergleicht mit dem was
heute angekündigt worden ist dann sind
das ungefähr zehn die hier geliefert
werden sollen aus Deutschland Frank
Großbritannien und den USA verglichen
mit den 300 also nur ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein aber das zeigt wie sehr
doch die Kluft wie groß doch die Kluft
ist zwischen dem Wunsch aus der Ukraine
und der Wirklichkeit westlicher
Waffenlieferungen
vielen Dank bis hierhin vielen Dank an
die beiden Kollegen Julia Held und
Florian neueren wir hätten noch mehrere
Fragen zu diskutieren aber die Zeit
drängt die Ukraine braucht Waffen so
viel ist klar geworden Dankeschön
nochmal nur welche Waffen genau und
welche dann auch geliefert werden sollen
darüber kann man schon mal den Überblick
verlieren wir wollen noch mal kurz
zeigen wie die Lage konkret aussieht was
denn die deutschen zusagen und
Lieferungen dann auch angeht
Iris t ist ein Boden gebundenes
Luftverteidigungssystem mittlerer
Reichweite so die militärische exakte
Bezeichnung für das was Deutschland
jetzt der Ukraine liefern will das
System der deutschen Waffenschmiede Deal
hier im Werbevideo Ziel zu der
momentanen modernsten mobilen Luftabwehr
die ukrainische Armee soll damit in die
Lage versetzt werden sich effektiver
gegen die Angriffe russischer Flugzeuge
Hubschrauber Raketen und Drohnen
verteidigen zu können neben ihres gibt
es die Zusage aus Bundeswehrbeständen
auch Mars 2 Raketenwerfer zu liefern
insgesamt vier Stück dazu ein modernes
ortungsradar um feindliche
Artilleriestellungen aufklären zu können
drei weitere Waffensystem aus
Deutschland für die Ukraine also neben
den schon versprochenen sieben
Panzerhaubitzen und 50 flugabwehrpanzer
vom Typ piepert wann geliefert wird noch
unklar schon in der Ukraine angekommen
sind Luftabwehrraketen Panzerfäuste und
millionenschuss Munition
ansonsten setzt die Bundesregierung
weiter auf den sogenannten Ringtausch
dabei liefern NATO Verbündete wie
Slowenien oder Tschechien Panzer aus
sowjetischer Produktionen die Ukraine im
Gegenzug erhalten Sie dann deutsches
Gerät wie den Schützenpanzer Marder auch
mit Griechenland ist ein solcher
Ringtausch laut Bundeskanzler Scholz
bereits fest vereinbart
an der Stelle lese ich gerade noch einen
Kommentar vor über Youtube an uns
herangetragen von Stefan Magna die NATO
sollte endlich massiv Waffen liefern und
sich nicht ständig um Putins
Befindlichkeiten sorgen ja ob das so
einfach ist das besprechen wir jetzt
unter anderem mit Gustav kressel wir
sehen uns schon er ist Politik und
Militärexperte vom Think Tank European
Council und Foren relations und
zugeschaltet aus Berlin schönen guten
Abend Herr Kessel guten Abend
wir haben gerade noch mal gesehen welche
Zusagen Deutschland gemacht hat und was
bislang geliefert wurde wie bewerten sie
denn den aktuellen Status quo
naja mich sehr gemischten Gefühlen also
erstmal dass ich gewisse Lieferungen
verzögern oder dass ich gewisse
Lieferungen Strecken über die Zeit das
war bekannt weil eben komplexere
Waffensysteme Panzer bitte 2000 zum
Beispiel oder auch der Gepard natürlich
einen Ausbildungs einen logistikvorlauf
brauchen das heißt Sie müssen Techniker
in der Ukraine ausbilden wie sie das
Ding warten können sie müssen die
Soldaten die bedienmannschaften
ausbilden und das dauert alles Zeit
das Problem bei Deutschland ist
gering täusche die ringtage zum Beispiel
der mit Tschechien der hat Sinn gemacht
weil Tschechien sozusagen ab Front wie
man das in Englisch sagt geliefert hat
also sofort die 72 ausgeschieden hat und
damit hat man Zeit gewonnen das ist 72
wird jetzt irgendwann im Herbst durch
deutsche Leopard ersetzt die nicht so
schnell einsatzbereit gemacht werden
konnten als die Tschechen 72 liefern der
Ringtausch die Marder nach Griechenland
zu schicken ist eine völlige
Verschwendung dieses Geräts weil die
griechischen bmp1 in der Qualität
deutlich schlechter sind und auch jetzt
erst wieder mal flott gemacht werden
müssen und erst viel später in die
Ukraine gehen können als wenn man die
Mader direkt geliefert hätte und da
kommen wir schon bei dem Kernpunkt es
gibt so gewisse selbstrestriktionen in
Deutschland Kampfpanzer Schützenpanzer
die man in Ukraine kaum versteht denn
gewisses altes gebrauchtes Gerät das im
deutschen Rüstungsschmieden hier oben
steht wir reden jetzt nicht vom
bundeswehrgerät sondern vom Gerät das
durch andere Länder zurückgegeben wurde
das ist im Grunde frei das wird
wahrscheinlich irgendwann auf dem
Schrottplatz landen oder es ist in der
Ukraine und da ist es halt in der
Ukraine schon besser aufgehoben ja wenn
Sie das aktuelle Kriegsgeschehen in der
Ukraine analysieren würden sie dann
sagen dass Russland nach ja anfänglichen
Schwierigkeiten die allen halben zu
beobachten waren jetzt seine Taktik
angepasst und verbessert hat denn
inzwischen hat man ja doch den Eindruck
dass zumindest an ausgesuchten Stellen
gerade an der Ostfront Russland die Ober
beginnt ja russland hat sein Verhalten
taktisch angepasst das macht keine
tiefen Manöver mehr also man trinkt
nicht
dutzende wenn ich hunderte Kilometer
tief in ukrainisches Territorium ein und
wundert sich dann dass man die Soldaten
nicht versorgen kann sondern man geht
relativ langsam Durchschnitts
Angriffsgeschwindigkeit ist 1,5
Kilometer pro Tag vor man zerschießt
systematisch mit Artillerie die
ukrainischen Stellungen und rückt dann
mit vielen Panzern auf diese vor so
minimiert man die eigenen Verluste die
hohen eigenen Verluste haben ja für die
sinkende Moral in der russischen Armee
vor allen Dingen gesorgt das hat man
jetzt auch behoben und so rückt man vor
und so minimiert man die eigenen
Verluste man maximiert die da Ukrainer
man nutzt die Schwäche der Ukraine im
Bereich Feuerkraft aus und maximiert die
eigene Überlegenheit und nutzt das
taktisch cleverer das geht natürlich
langsam und es ist sozusagen noch nicht
Tage Abend hier war auch natürlich die
Ukraine sich jetzt neu einstellt wie
Russland vorgeht und auch den Russen
harte Verluste zufügt aber in einem
abnutzungskrieg in einem langfristigen
abnutzungskrieg sind das natürlich für
die Ukraine deutlich schlechtere Karten
als noch im Frühling weil man eben nicht
weiß wie viel Material aus dem Westen
nachkommt weil die eigene
Rüstungsindustrie zu einem sehr großen
Teil zerstört wurde durch Luftangriffe
und man jetzt nicht weiß wie man diesen
abnutzungskrieg langfristig durchhalten
will
danke bis hierhin Uwe Lachmann sagt uns
oder schreibt uns über Facebook was
bezweckt man mit der Unterstützung dass
der Krieg nicht so schnell aufhört
Profit für die Rüstungsindustrie schickt
lieber weiße Flaggen in die Ukraine
damit das Sterben aufhört diesen
Standpunkt vertreten einige aber in der
Ukraine ist das soweit ich weiß nicht
die Mehrheitsmeinung ein Vorwurf der aus
Kiew immer wieder erhoben wird zuletzt
auch wieder von Präsident silence Gesetz
ist das Deutschland zu langsam und auch
zu zöger ich agiere würden Sie dem
zustimmen und wenn ja warum ist das so
aus ihrer Sicht
also es gibt den gewissen Bereichen gibt
es sehr lange innenpolitische
Diskussionen es gibt oder man hat in der
Ukraine auch das Gefühl dass aus
Deutschland und auch aus anderen Teilen
westeuropos der Ukraine ein Sieg
eigentlich nicht zugetraut wird und das
was man liefert eigentlich nur sozusagen
dem Druck geschuldet ist der aufgebaut
wird durch andere alliierte und durch
die eigene Bevölkerung die öffentliche
Meinung in Deutschland ist ja
überwiegend auf der Seite der Ukraine
und wünscht sich eine entschiedene
Haltung der Bundesregierung und das
erweckt zu den Eindruck des
strategielosigkeit dass man getrieben
ist von Umfragedaten und dass man ein
Waffensystem verspricht wenn die
Umfragewerte im Keller liegen aber dass
man keinen systematischen Plan hat wie
man Ukraine unter die Arme greift einen
abnutzungskrieg zu gewinnen welche
welche Zeitlinien man planen muss welche
Güter bereitzustellen sondern dass das
alles noch sehr ad hoc ist und dass das
nicht wirklich durch die militärischen
Notwendigkeiten bedingt ist sondern
durch politische Stimmung
sie haben gerade die öffentliche Meinung
angesprochen das ist ganz interessant in
dem Zusammenhang könnte die folgende
Studie nämlich auch von relevant sein
die ihr Haus der European counsel und
von relations gemacht hat und einige
Ergebnisse dieser Studie die können wir
uns jetzt gerade noch mal gemeinsam
anschauen
Russland trägt die Hauptschuld am Krieg
in der Ukraine das Sagen in Finnland 90
Prozent der Befragten Großbritannien und
Polen schließen sich dem mit jeweils 83%
an in Deutschland finden nur 66 Prozent
das Russland für den Krieg
verantwortlich ist 20 Prozent weisen der
Ukraine der EU oder den USA die Schuld
zu in Italien sind lediglich 56 Prozent
der Meinung das Russland die Hauptschuld
am Krieg trägt sollte wegen Russlands
angriffskriegs mehr in die eigene
Verteidigung investiert werden ja sagen
52 Prozent der Befragten in Polen und
nehmen dafür auch in Kauf Das Bereiche
wie Gesundheit und Bildung
möglicherweise weniger Geld bekommen
Schweden folgt dem mit 50 und
Deutschland mit 41 Prozent Italien auch
hier wieder Schlusslicht mit nur 14%
Zustimmung die Frage ob alle
wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen zu Russland
gekappt werden sollten beantworten in
Deutschland
50% mit ja 45 Prozent sagen auch die
kulturellen Beziehungen sollten
abgebrochen werden bei den
diplomatischen Beziehungen sind es 39
Prozent der Bevölkerung
ja da waren doch Herr Kessel einige
interessante Zahlen dabei gehen wir es
gerade noch mal durch hat es sie
überrascht dass in Deutschland nur 66
Prozent der Menschen Russland für den
Krieg hauptverantwortlich machen in
anderen Ländern war es noch weniger aber
man könnte ja denken die Zahlen werden
vielleicht höher
wenn ich mit zum einen Teil der
öffentlichen Debatte anschaue ist das
eigentlich nicht überraschend also es
gibt ja in allen Shows oder in allen
größeren Debatten immer jemand der sagt
ja eigentlich ist die
NATO-Osterweiterung Schuld eigentlich
sind die Ukrainer selber schuld also es
gibt diese Meinung ja auch im
öffentlichen Raum und dass die einen
Widerhall in der Gesellschaft findet ist
jetzt eigentlich
nicht nicht sonderlich verwunderlich ich
war hier durch Deutschland eigentlich
positiv überrascht in vielen Fällen vor
allen Dingen was zum Beispiel die die
Bereitschaft dann auch wirtschaftliche
Last zu tragen durch diesen Krieg angeht
wenn man sich anschaut das ja Teile der
Industrie im März noch getrommelt haben
dass jede Art von embargo also den
Zusammenbruch des Sozialstaats bedeuten
und alle möglichen Horrorszenarien an
die Wand geworfen haben das hat doch
weniger weit weniger Leute beeindruckt
als gedacht und vielleicht haben Sie
auch gesehen dass mittlerweile der Staat
nicht zusammenbricht also ich ich sehe
das die welche Meinung hier nicht zu
kritisch ich finde die höchste die
deutsche öffentliche Meinung ist in
vielen Fällen
mehr in der Lage als Teile des
politischen Berlins die sich mehr um die
eigenen Befindlichkeiten kümmern ich
finde auch die Solidarität für die
Ukraine ist in der deutschen Bevölkerung
ja durchaus ausgeprägt und und auch
wirklich stark
Rom fragt über Youtube wenn die
Bundeswehr nicht viel hat versteht das
jeder warum lässt man die
Industrieproduktion nicht hochfahren
die Industrieproduktion fährt in einigen
Teilen in einigen Staaten auch wirklich
hoch in Deutschland ist ist da das
Problem dass zu eben zu vielen Klassen
von Fahrzeugen ist keine
exportbescheinigung gibt das heißt die
Rüstungsindustrie die meisten Geräte die
ja in die Ukraine geliefert werden
könnten die stehen nicht bei der
Bundeswehr rum sondern die stehen im
Bereich der Rüstungsindustrie das sind
zurückgenommene Fahrzeuge aus anderen
Streitkräften in Europa und zum Teil aus
der Bundeswehr die schon ausgeschieden
sind und da wird gezankt ob man die
jetzt exportieren darf oder soll ob man
das nicht tut oder ob man erst warten
soll auf andere NATO starten dass die
vorangehen diese Rüstungsklassen zu
liefern und damit verliert man Zeit was
die Produktion von Munition angeht in
Schweden in den USA in der Slowakei in
Polen wird die munitionsproduktion
hochgekurbelt das Problem ist natürlich
das geschieht auch nicht über Nacht
Industriepolitik und die die
industrielle Vorbereitung für so keinen
Krieg auf dieser Größe wie wir es in der
Ukraine erleben die braucht natürlich
ihre Vorbereitung die braucht ihre Zeit
wir kämpfen hier und die Ukraine kämpft
hier auf einer Front die 1200 km lang
ist es werden auf ukrainischer Seite um
die 5 bis 6000 Schuss Artillerie
Munition pro Tag verschossen auf
russischer Seite sind das zu spitzen
Tagen an Angriffen 50.000 Schuss
Artillerie Munition pro Tag pro Tag und
es haben viele in Europa einfach nicht
begriffen was ein Krieg der zwei größten
landarmeen in Europa industriell und
materiell bedeutet
aber muss man dann nicht vielleicht doch
fast Michael jagi zustimmen der uns
schreibt die Ukraine kann nichts mehr
machen außer so früh wie möglich mit
Russland Verhandlungen aufzunehmen sonst
verlieren sie noch mehr Gebiete würde
das was sie gerade beschreiben nicht
sozusagen dieser Meinung Vorschub
leisten dass man am Ende ja eigentlich
gar keine Perspektive keine Chance hat
die die hat zwei Probleme das erste ist
russland will nicht verhandelt das
zweite ist wenn wenn die Ukraine die
russischen Bedingungen erfüllt dann geht
auch auf der ukrainischen Seite das
Sterben weiter weil es dann ein
Besatzungsregime gibt dessen Resultat
der wir ja in Gutschein anderen Städten
erlebt haben die Ukraine führt zurzeit
einen Krieg in dem sie ihre eine eigene
Überlegenheit an Menschen nämlich
dadurch dass sie durch die general mobil
machen durch die hohe Anzahl von
Freiwilligen hat mehr Fußsoldaten hat
als die als die russische Seite
versucht so weit wie möglich zu ihrem
Vorteil zu nutzen in Ortschaften zu
kämpfen im bebauten Gebiet zu kämpfen um
in Wäldern zu kämpfen
zu sehen dass man die Ukraine ins dass
man die russischen Streitkräfte ins in
vertriegelände zwingt und dann einfach
durch die in kaufname eigene
Opfer an Menschen ob Verluste an
Rüstungsmaterial auf der russischen
Seite zu erzwingen das ist brutal aber
das ist natürlich eine Gesellschaft die
mit dem Rücken zur Wand und die als
einzige Alternative die kulturelle und
soziale Auslöschung hat ein eine
verständliche Taktik aber deshalb spielt
ja auch zielensky so stark auf die
schweren Waffen weil er natürlich das
auch nicht sein schon leid ist bzw auch
nicht ewig durchhalten kann jeden Tag
über 100
ukrainischen Familien das
Kondolenzschreiben für Söhne für Brüder
und für für Onkel zu überreichen aber
aus ukrainischer Sicht es geht ums
Überleben und sozusagen ein ein
kapitulationsfrieden steht nicht
Diskussion weil ein kapitulationsfrieden
noch schlimmeres bringt als der Krieg
jetzt schon ist wie sehen Sie denn die
Situation mittel bis langfristig es
heißt ja immer die Ukraine dürfen den
Krieg nicht verlieren beziehungsweise
manchmal auch andersrum Russland dürfe
ihn nicht gewinnen aber wie würden Sie
jetzt zum Beispiel definieren was wann
der Fall ist
das hängt zu einem erheblichen Maße von
der Bereitschaft des Westens ab die
Ukraine auch militärisch zu unterstützen
und es gibt
vor allen Dingen auch in den USA auch
noch Bestände an gebrauchten Gerät aus
der Zeit des Kalten Krieges die man
anzapfen kann das dauert zum Teil im
Bereich der Vorbereitung eben Logistik
und Ausbildung durchaus noch eine Zeit
aber das kann man machen
da trifft jetzt Washington was man auch
zu Deutschland sagen muss die bisherigen
Zusagen waren zu zögerlich ich hoffe nur
dass hier dass ich in Washington hier
die Stimmung dann entscheiden da und
schneller auch wandeln und wenden wird
aber es gibt das Material um der Ukraine
zu ermöglichen hier diesen Krieg
durchaus zu gewinnen beziehungsweise
einem einem kapitulationsfrieden zu
entgehen das Material gibt es der
politische Wille muss im Westen nur
wachsen
Ismael 04 schreibt uns noch mal anfangs
war man ja überrascht wie stark die
Ukraine Schienen wie schwach Russland
erleben wir hier gerade einen
gamechanger dreht sich die militärische
Lage gerade
wir sehen dass sich die logistische Lage
in einigen Bereichen dreht ich würde
noch vorsichtig sein zu sagen die
Ukraine ist jetzt sozusagen am
absteigenden Ast die Ukraine hat große
Schwierigkeiten in eigenen Bereichen man
muss aber auch sagen dass zum Beispiel
in Carson jetzt eine gegen Offensive der
Ukraine noch läuft und gerade am
heutigen Tag Erfolge gebracht hat wenn
man hier zum Beispiel eine nebenstellung
erreicht dann werden erhebliche
ukrainische Kräfte wieder frei die man
wieder in den Dom was bringen kann auch
gepanzerte Kräfte mechanisierte Kräfte
also es ist noch nicht aller Tage Abend
es ist nur enorm brenzlig und es ist den
Ukrainer natürlich auch klar dass das
was Sie erreichen können an Frieden oder
an Sicherheit dass sie das nur über
enorme Menschenopfer erreichen werden
können und das ist für Sie natürlich
keine sehr schöne Perspektive
wie schätzen Sie das ein ihr Kollege
Herr Fried Münkler zum Beispiel im Fokus
war heute ein Gespräch mit ihm oder
beziehungsweise ein Aufsatz von ihm geht
davon aus dass Russland den Krieg
langfristig gewinnt einfach aufgrund der
Tatsache dass die Ukraine der wir erst
nannte asymmetrischen Kriegsführung
nichts entgegenzusetzen hätte und auch
der Drohung mit atomaren Potenzial und
auch der Westen irgendwie da drauf noch
keine überzeugende strategische Antwort
gefunden habe wie würden sie die
Situation beurteilen
das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so also die
die Drohung mit der großen Atombombe mit
dem großen finalen nuklearen Krieg die
ist Teil der russischen psychologischen
Kampfführung schon seit geraumer Zeit
aber erstens Russland wenn Russland
gegen die NATO einen Atomkrieg anfangen
würde müsste es sich auch Gedanken
machen zu welchen Bedingungen es da
rauskommt außer jetzt der totalen
eigenen Auslöschung und da hat Russland
in der hochwertigen Situation wo auch
die konventionellen Streitkräfte in der
Ukraine gebunden sind keine guten
Chancen und nukleare Kriegsführung und
konventionelle Kriegsführung müssen sich
immer ergänzen sonst kommt man dann
irgendwo hin
was die Ukraine nuklear ausradieren
halte ich auch für eine nichtgangbare
oder eine nicht wählbare Option von der
russischen Seite abgesehen von den
internationalen folgen dass man dann
auch die neutralen verliert die Russland
jetzt in der sanktionsfrage die Stange
halten gibt es die lohnenden
militärischen Ziele nicht für einen
nuklearen Angriff das einzige lohnende
politische Ziel für einen
atomanschlag wäre Kiew da müsst ihr aber
Russland auch erklären man müsste Putin
vor seinen eigenen Publikum fast der
eigenen russisch-orthodoxen Kirche
erklären warum man die Stadt die
Heiligtümer die Kirchen die man ja als
die geburts- oder Geburtsort der
russischen orthodoxen Seele
bezeichnet jetzt in strahlenden Schutt
verwandelt hat und das geht sich
politisch nicht aus sonst man kann mit
konventioneller Feuerkraft das sieht man
in mariopol dieselben Effekte erzielen
wie durch einen Atombombenabwurf aber
weder mariopol jetzt noch noch jetzt
selber dort und jetzt als total
zerstörte Staaten bringen jetzt die
Wände im Krieg oder werfen die Ukraine
moralisch aus dem Krieg ein
Atombombenabwurf würde den den
Widerstands Willen der Ukrainer
wahrscheinlich nur verhärten
all das ist sozusagen dieses nukleares
Schreckenszenario ist alles leeres
Gefasel wenn man es sich durchdenkt
wohin das führt und was ist Russland
bringt im Vergleich zu was es Russland
kostet kommt man in allen Optionen immer
auf den Alternativen Ast es gibt diese
nukleare Kriegsgefahr zur Zeit nicht die
ist psychologische Kriegsführung des
Krems und ein Hirngespinst in unseren
Köpfen klare Worte von Gustav kressel
letzte Frage kommt von wanderkalli wie
wird Russland reagieren wenn Schweden
und Finnland in der NATO sind das ist ja
momentan auch Gegenstand der
Diskussionen der Prozess läuft
ja
russland hat Seemanöver in der Ostsee
anberaumt Russland fliegt auch mit
Flugzeugen hin und wieder in den
schwedischen in den finnischen Luftraum
es würde mich nicht überraschen wenn
russische U-Boote auch in die
Hoheitsgewässer Schwedens und Finnlands
eindringen würden und ähnliche
Provokationen durchführen würden
das Ende vom Gaslieferungen das Ende von
Stromlieferungen auch das sind
Druckmittel die russland hat militärisch
kann es zurzeit gegen diesen
nato-beitrag nicht vorgehen denn die
militärischen Mittel die man im Raum hat
die stehen jetzt in der Ukraine die
sechs der Medien
beim Baltikum in Finnland steht also
Raum St Petersburg die hat allein bei
dem Angriff auf karchiv einen großen
Teil ihrer gepanzerten Fahrzeuge schon
eingebüßt und hat sich schwere
organisieren müssen die marinen von
Trier aus Kaliningrad war in mariopol
und jetzt in poparsenal im Einsatz das
sind ein Großteil der Bataillone
abgekämpft und die anderen stehen jetzt
in der Ukraine im Einsatz es gibt
zurzeit aus russischer Sicht die
Möglichkeit nicht gegen etwas Schweden
oder gegen etwa Finnland militärisch
vorzugehen
sagt der Politik und Militärexperte
Gustav Ressel ganz herzlichen Dank für
das Gespräch einen schönen Abend nach
Berlin vielen herzlichen Dank ja und
auch ein ganz herzlichen Dank natürlich
wie immer an euch für die Fragen und
Kommentare wir bedanken uns fürs
Mitmachen und wünschen euch noch einen
schönen Abend und hoffentlich ein
schönes langes Wochenende bis demnächst
macht's gut ciao ciao